Why do you recommend that cancer patients don't take glutamate?
Well because
In general cancer is fed through multiple different sources cancer cells are remember rapidly replicating and because they're rapidly replicating
They're very hungry. So they need a lot of fuel in order to continue their metabolic processes continue to live and thrive and to continue to replicate
So they're hungry cells
So typically cancer is fed through glucose. So if you remember
seventh grade biology glucose goes through
glycolysis and
produces
an end point
two end points that then and it produces two ATP and it goes into the crem cycle and
produces a lot of ATP. That's how you produce energy. So glucose is a is how you make energy and that's how you run cells. So
Cancer tends to grow through glucose through glycolysis but not through the crem cycle oddly it ends up
because of the excess oxidative stress in the cell it
starts to use lactate as a fuel and
It's very inefficient, but to cancer cells because they're rapidly replicating. They're not functioning well and they're functioning inefficiently
So that's why you'd say cancer patients should stay away from sugar. Which I agree all cancer patients should stay away from sugar
But as cancer is growing it can use other things for fuel and it could have been used in the adolescents
glutamine and
Methionine are probably the two most common amino acids that cancer could use for fuel
glutamine is also
an amino acid that's unique in that it helps stimulate growth
Rapid growth. That's why you would take glutamine to help
heal
epithelial cells
of your gut. So typically glutamine as a
supplement is used as a gut healing supplement because
Your gut cells
Use that to help replicate new cells and you could heal your gut quite well by using glutamine
It's a beneficial substance to help turn over cells in the gut and heal cells in the gut
Well, just that little bit of knowledge should help the average person just go. Yeah, I don't want to help grow cancer cells
especially if you have a
endocarsaloma
That glutamine would typically feed quite well. So I
typically recommend
That you don't necessarily need to go on a glutamine free diet because that's impossible
You need protein in order to make the right
variety of
lymphocytes to kill cancer cells
But you don't need to be taking excess glutamine in supplements
So it's not uncommon that we have a cancer patient come to us and
They maybe did some study on well. I need to heal my gut because now I need to get all right
It got this diagnosed of cancer. Maybe they're working with a nutritious and said and with diagnosed cancer
We really need to heal your gut. We need to get you on glutamine. I think that's the very wrong thing to do
Cancer patients should not be taking excess glutamine like that in a supplemental form
Because it couldn't literally be feeling the cancer
so
Typically I say no glutamine for cancer patient list there and full remissioned out. We're working on some other cobalt
rigidies
It just makes sense to stay away from something that couldn't possibly fuel it